okay this is phenomenal thank you hey I
know it's hard to navigate that train
though yeah I am i stylus has been
sweating his butt off carrying it for me
it's like being a bride you know they're
carrying around the train behind you
yeah
yeah this is even heavier than my
wedding dress though so it's got some
weight to it
who was that by he's gorgeous this is
Christian Siriano and he made it in this
really beautiful color for me and it was
very springtime and you got your
eyeshadow to match yes all the purple
mountain Majesties you have got it all
going on right now I mean do you feel I
mean I know you know how on fire you
right now but how does it feel to you
it's been a crazy month I mean it's been
a month since my album came out and
we've started a tour and done all this
promo and obviously coming into the ACMs
it's been crazy but really fun and you
know when they told me that I broke the
streaming record for a woman in country
ever like that just didn't it's not
computing so it sat in yet or no I mean
I I don't even know how to wrap my head
around a number like that but I am very
honored and you know it was a labor of
love to make the record and put it out
and so I feel like it's just very
validating yeah you did this tremendous
collaboration the other day I mean the
performance with with Miranda and the
photo with all the powerful women is
there a chance that you guys would
actually do a collaborative song
together what went out released one well
I mean we're going on tour together
later this fall so maybe we'll write
some songs well we're out there oh I
think that's a yes yeah I mean she's
such a great friend and to be able to
support her on the road this year is
gonna be really fun for me and I feel
like I'm gonna learn a lot you know what
would you say to all just because I know
that you try it out for all the reality
shows and look at you now oh it's so
impressive what would you say to the
judges to people out there now because
it's like you know they can get it wrong
and it's like you know well you know
there's just so many people that
audition that people fall through the
cracks I mean I think Hillary Scott and
Lady a was rejected from American Idol
as well you know it all worked out so I
would just say if you got rejected from
one of those auditions or whatever
just be patient and keep at it and
sometimes the long road is a more
fruitful one true you could be Mary
Morris right good
congratulations on everything you look
phenomenal
[Music]